un moniteur de ski c'était à l'échelon
artisanale on s'arrêtait pour prendre un
petit pot pour manger la tarte aux
myrtilles
aujourd'hui nous arrivons sur le côté
industriel l'industrialisation d'un
métier voilà ce que dénonçait ce
moniteur de ski à la fin des années 70 à
cette époque les sports d'hiver se
démocratise les stations se multiplier
de plus en plus de personnes veulent pas
prendre à skis une foule qui gênait ce
moniteur en 1977 sur les pistes ya un
petit problème on est un petit peu
cernés par derrière par la droite par la
gauche et pour travailler c'est plus
difficile parce que les gens sont un
petit peu crispé tendu un petit problème
quand même à plus de l'affluence les
professeurs doivent aussi s'accommoder
d'une nouvelle clientèle les stations
françaises attire les skieurs
internationaux alors il faut s'adapter
tant bien que mal
l'homme a été un peu pris de court pris
de vitesse par cette évolution du zinc
dans une station de val d'isère par
exemple ou en quatre ans on est passé de
20% à 50% d'étrangers mais un petit peu
de mal à s'adapter pour les langues par
exemple et pour suivre la cadence les
moniteurs sont aussi plus nombreux
l'école de ski français une institution
depuis 1945 compte aujourd'hui dix sept
mille professionnels contre 5500 dans
les années 70
et à travers les décennies les
silhouettes rouge de le sf ont dû
s'adapter aux évolutions de la pratique
c'est une profession où on se doit
également de dessus ce qui se fait de
faire correspondre et la technique et le
matériel
l'école du ski français représentent
aujourd'hui 85% du marché des cours de
ski dans l'hexagone une omniprésence sur
les pistes face à laquelle certains
moniteurs indépendants résistent
j'ai la chance d'être à isola 2000
depuis plus de 30 ans d'avoir une
clientèle très fidèle et j'ai beaucoup
d'amis et c'est le bouche à oreille qui
me permet de travailler dans de bonnes
conditions
si quelques skieurs sont encore formé
par ces moniteurs indépendant la
majorité soit deux millions de personnes
passent chaque année par le sm
[Musique]